with this record going into it where was
your head where was your heart head was
in head and heart button a lot of
gratitude yeah a lot of gratitude and
very awake and interested in
collaborating with people and the same
one what comes of it
and what you do sort of get in that
headspace of where you want to
collaborate where do you start with your
list is it are you going to people
personally are you trying to like how
are you building this sort of group
around you to collaborate with yeah or
some of it's coming from the sort of
obsessive credit reading I'll do on
records yeah who does this who did that
who's that person what's happening over
there someone like Julian Michaels who I
become aware of through her her own
songs issues and then her EP which I
loved that was just one of those things
if going well I'd love to write with her
and a guy called Justin Trant who is a
great writer had written all the songs
with Julia and so seeking them out it
was a goal of mine but a lot of the
other collaborators came through a guy
who co-executor record with me dan
McCarroll who knows pretty much
everybody
and it's great at saying you should
write with these guys you should work
with this person see what happens
Julia Michaels is so young and so
talented you almost hate her
oh she's amazing absolutely amazing
she's so inspiring to be around and so
fluid in her artistry yeah it just is
very quick and completely unfiltered do
you know how fast you know that you're
going to click with somebody when you
have to sit down to write with them I
don't know that you do some you don't
know I mean sometimes of course it's
it's it's instant and others I think
take a beat but I do think something
either comes within the first within the
first hour or so yeah or it's you know
some people take a while till to feel
comfortable yeah I feel confident people
immediately right there anybody sure but
that's not always the way for the other
people right and with I was even with
Carrie Underwood we saw her right before
you guys won the award was the first
time that anybody had
seen her were you like us with the
anticipation of that sort of return yeah
but at the same time I think it was when
she came out and sang that song it was
more about the performance because let
me know she was up on stage we're a long
ways off she looked exactly the same
running me and sang amazing you know
yeah and that's sort of the openness in
your and your sort of in your business
especially in country where the audience
expects transparency you know other
artists wouldn't have said I had 50
stitches in my face you don't have to
because you really couldn't tell but
that's just who she is and it's sort of
the community that you guys have there
with that honesty which then built that
anticipation for for all of us
right do you feel that honesty with the
with the audience that you guys more so
in that country world you know that some
thought the fans expected in a negative
way
but it's sort of expected no no I think
I think it always comes down to the
artist
everybody's different with what they
feel comfortable letting everybody into
right yeah some people tell too much
right everybody has told too much at
some point especially now weird what is
it what's the term D selfing yes yeah
there's too much D cell thing going yeah
yeah no that's true how did how did
Nicole wind up on the record she was
hung yeah I was working on a song called
female and it was the perfect song to
have her sing on and have a studio at
the house so I went and got her and she
reluctantly came chastity she's not
comfortable singing no but I I luckily
got her on a microphone and that was the
sort of intent behind the song did it
persuade her even more did it make it
easier to get her down the stairs
she loved the song I got sent the song
the day after the three riders had
written it yeah I wasn't a writer on it
but they just spoke to me
yeah expected both of us and this was so
is it is it Ron to say it's a not a
reaction but it's it is you well it's
got branded that okay kind of
immediately but if the song is is about
many many things that being one of them
that the three riders two guys and a
girl who wrote the song Shane McAnally
Ross Kauffman and Nicole galleon also
probably not coincidentally also have
all three of the writers so yeah a lot
kind of that song right a little song
and when fans do find out that you guys
have done a song together the
conversation immediately turns to well
of course they're gonna do it duets
album now will not be learning I'll
speak my wife here it's not gonna it's
not gonna happen and I want being big
little Ozzy this right here do you find
that do you find that you can appreciate
what sort of each other does as fans or
are you too inside you know me can she
appreciate your music as a fan should
appreciate it as show or movie as a fan
or you just too inside no I think we can
separate those two yeah there's two
things yeah definitely but I'm I like
playing her songs when I'm working on
them at and and if not so much for her
reaction but the way I feel okay playing
a song for her yeah speaks to me a lot
that's the way I am with a lot of songs
so I have a handful of people that I
like playing songs for and I'm
interested in how I feel when I'm
playing it for them really sometimes
even more than their reaction yeah
because they may say oh I love this and
I might think oh I don't like the way I
feel playing this for you right so yeah
that makes me question what's going on
but I like that I like using that kind
of way of seeing where I am within
sonically and genre wise on this album
it's it's many different directions do
you decide to go that far on one track
and in this far on another track
compared to where many people may think
that you should live or that you
naturally live musically I guess I don't
think about any anything when I'm
creating and that's correct which is
really what the title alludes to
graffiti you that the graffiti really
comes from that seeing the studio is
like a blank canvas yeah and just
getting and painting just no no
preconceived ideas no no no John Rizzo
boundaries no no nothing just start
playing you know I love playing I love
rhythm I love I get inspired by sounds
and rhythms it's you can definitely feel
that in this album do you feel are you a
better singer better guitar player I
don't know I try not to think of those
things separately no because they can't
be no for me they've always come
together as one
because you play you meet people who are
in their heart a guitar player who sings
right or a singer who also plays the
guitar yeah well I because I started
doing both yeah I was always just a
little kid in the room singing and
playing and trying to write songs yeah
you know so those things don't feel
separate to me at all